[Musique]
encore
et
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans le 7-8 week-end nous allons parler
actualités mais aussi loisirs
voici les titres de ce vendredi 19
février l'actualité ce sont les
violences urbaines contre des policiers
qui ont eu lieu à poissy le week-end
dernier et en début de semaine visite du
ministre de l'intérieur réunion avec les
acteurs locaux
nous parlerons de ce sujet et des
solutions à y apporter avec notre invité
sidi el haimer directeur de
l'association insertion formation
éducation prévention
lee fait nous parlerons également de
l'appel aux dons lancé par le président
de l'assemblée nationale richard ferrand
pour restaurer la salle du jeu de paume
du château de versailles
objectif récupérer 1,83 million de roof
enfin nous vous proposerons aussi les
idées c'hoazh loisirs de célia guettent
son gros avec de la cuisine presque sans
sucre et des sorties pour les vacances
scolaires juste avant cela la députée la
république en marche de la 5e
circonscription des yvelines
yaël brawn pie v a reçu jeudi le soutien
de l'ensemble des députés
elle est aussi présidente de la
commission des lois cela fait suite aux
injures et menaces à caractère
antisémite dont elle a été la cible
jeudi dernier la parlementaire avait
publié sur twitter un mail rempli d'un
sud qu'elle a reçues ce n'est pas la
première fois que la députée est
confronté à de telles insultes
elle avait déjà déposé plainte pour des
attaques sexistes et antisémites et des
menaces en juillet 2018
le parquet de paris s'est saisie de la
faire on écoute sa réaction c'est
toujours en fait la boule au ventre qui
ne s'estompe pas parce que c'est
extrêmement violent c'est indigne et on
a du mal à imaginer qu'aujourd'hui on va
avoir ce type de message en 2020 terre
d'antisémitisme et comme toute forme de
racisme est absolument incompréhensible
et qu'elle skip que ça puisse encore
aujourd'hui s'exprimer aussi aussi
clairement c'est c'est effrayant et
c'est ça qui fait que effectivement ça
ne passe pas en revanche ce qui est
absolument formidable c'est l'unité
république
yen qui s'est immédiatement manifesté
soit hier dans l'hémicycle où depuis où
je reçois des messages soient d'élus
soit de citoyens qui m'exprime leur
soutien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comme je vous le disais en titre ces
derniers jours ont été marqués par des
violences urbaines
à poissy le week-end dernier des
policiers ont été pris pour cible par
des tirs de mortiers d'artifice de la
part d'une trentaine d'individus dans le
quartier beauregard à poissy
une vidéo a notamment été publié par le
syndicat des commissaires de police où
on pouvait entendre tu es là tu es l'est
mardi 16 février la tension n'était
toujours pas retombée
une nouvelle fois des policiers ont
essuyé des jets de cocktails molotov
un adolescent de 16 ans a été interpellé
pour parler à de nous avec nous par don
de ce sujet sidi el haimer bonsoir alors
vous êtes directeur général de
l'association insertion formation
éducation et prévention
li fep et vous êtes également conseillé
à la région ile de france et premier
adjoint en charge des affaires sociales
à la ville de mantes la jolie
tout d'abord quel est votre regard sur
ces violences qui ont fait l'actualité
ces derniers jours à poissy oui
alors bien sûr je condamne avec la plus
grande force ce qui s'est passé et je
l'occasion d'en parler avec le maire
karl olive pour le soutenir
alors il ya je pense
on est toujours dans les vacances à
chaque vacances scolaires
on sent qu'il ya à la force des réseaux
sociaux
donc le fait de montrer à près de rendre
sa visible je pense que voilà c'est un
peu ces ingrédients qui font que des
fois malheureusement on a des grosses
problématiques et des violences urbaines
envers les sens de l'enfant alors donc
suite à ces violences le week-end
dernier
lundi 15 février le ministre de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin s'est rendu
au commissariat de police de poissy le
maire dans la foulée le mardi à
organiser une réunion avec les acteurs
locaux pour essayer de trouver des
solutions lors de la visite de gérald
darmanin ministre de l'intérieur et il a
déclaré je cite à travers les policiers
de poids si je voudrais m'adresser à
tous les policiers et gendarmes qui
vivent ces faits quasiment tous les
jours et la face à des jeunes garçons
qui ont entre 12 et 17 ans quel est le
profil selon vous des jeunes garçons de
12 à 17 ans dont parle gérald darmanin
je pense que ce sont des jeunes qui sont
en échec scolaire qui sont pas forcément
à l'école qu'ils ont un lien avec les
parents qui est très difficile et qui
sont marginalisés et c'est ce public là
que les éducateurs des lits faits vont
rencontrer sur le terrain est alors pour
vous que faut-il mettre en place quelle
est la solution de voir les pistes de
solution pour éviter ce genre de
violences urbaines que ce soit à poissy
ou ailleurs d'abord bien rendre d'abord
rencontrer ces jeunes là bien identifier
ce qui cause problème et les éducateurs
de lits faits font tout un travail
auprès d'eux au quotidien à la sab le
mans pour
les orienter vers les dispositifs ce
soit les réinscrire à la mise sur le
canon les inscrire tout simplement
essayer de les remettre en situation de
reprise scolaire ou d'accès à l'emploi
et donc on a signé tout un travail et
bien sûr être plutôt dans des solutions
de réparation
et justement qu'est ce que vous mettez
en place vous ali fait pour ses
solutions de réparation
on est par exemple on fait des stages
avec les pompiers ont mis en place des
chantiers éducatifs ce soit des
réflexions de all 28 ans descend les
escaliers pour recoller les il
s'approprie davantage leurs locaux et
que les parents s'y soient un peu fier
d'eux donc voilà c'est un peu ces
mesures là il ya des séjours de rupture
qui sont organisées il ya des actions
sportives notamment par le sport c'est
très important
on les sortir un peu de leur quotidien
les sortir aussi du quartier c'est
important certains travaillent à free
individuelles et de groupe
alors je rappelle quelques chiffres de
votre association vous suivez 2270
jeunes vous avez traité 3 plus de 3000
problème pour ne citer que ça alors on a
bien compris dès que vous avez identifié
ces jeunes du cou qui ont des problèmes
mais d'abord comment on fait pour
établir le dialogue avec ces jeunes dont
vous parlez déscolarisés qui n'ont pas
de lien avec leur famille ou très peu
comment ça se passe pour établir ce
dialogue
ça peut mettre du temps mais les
éducateurs
justement nos équipes n'ont pas de
bureau ils ont des bureaux
administratifs mais j'ai tout leur
travail c'est le fond sur la route
auxerre qui vont à la rencontre des
jeunes se présentent créer une relation
de confiance et quand la relation de
confiance et est fait à ce moment-là bon
voilà la personne se confie sur ces
problématiques et compris le familial et
après voilà il ya un suivi personnalisé
qui sait qu'après voilà on arrive à
sortir des jeunes de la galère merci
sidi el haimer d'avoir été avec nous en
tout cas pour ceux 7,8 week end dans le
reste de l'actualité le ministre de la
santé olivier vers en a fait le point
jeudi soir sur l'épidémie de kobe de 19
il a notamment annoncé que la durée de
l'isolément de tous les patients
positifs seraient allongés à partir de
lundi 22 février
elle passerait de sept à dix jours
l'isolément de dix jours était déjà
appliquée pour les personnes contaminées
par le variant sud africain ou
brésiliens l'isolément des cas contacts
presse quant à lui à sept jours
également des cas de kovy 19 ont été
recensés à la maison d'arrêt de bois
d'arcy
selon force ouvrière sur 180
surveillants testé par l' agence
régionale de santé
dix ont été déclarés positifs à cela
s'ajoutent aux 11 autres cas des
personnes qui se sont fait tester de
façon indépendante
du côté des 840 détenus neuf cas
positifs auraient pour le moment était
comptabilisée
l'administration pénitentiaire n'a pas
confirmé ces chiffres
pour le moment et dans l'actualité
également nous accueillons justin
brasier bonsoir bonsoir la célèbre salle
du jeu de paume de versailles a besoin
d'être restaurée salle qui tient son nom
d'un célèbre événement le serment du jeu
de paume
un appel aux dons a été lancé pour
restaurer cette salle oui c'est une
volonté de la part de richard ferrand
donc le président de l'assemblée
nationale
après avoir échangé avec catherine
pégard la présidente du château de
versailles
l'appel a été lancé mardi auprès des
députés il devrait ensuite
progressivement s'ouvrir à l'ensemble
des élus que la population alors
pourquoi c'est important de restaurer à
cette salle du jeu de paume et bien
parce qu'elle fait partie de notre
histoire
c'est un symbole de la république et
puis de la démocratie française
écouter didier baichère le député de la
première circonscription des yvelines
on connaît souvent versailles évidemment
pour son château est plutôt pour son
pour des angles de la royauté mais on
sait peu ou pas assez que versailles est
aussi un haut lieu de la constitution de
la république en particulier avec cette
salle du jeu de paume qui a quand même
donné naissance à la déclaration des
droits de l'homme et du citoyen en 1789
donc c c'est important pour l'histoire
de continuer à préserver cet endroit est
de pouvoir l'ouvrir plus largement au
public et le montrer dans un état que
son état d'origine en fait c'est alors
j'estime qu'elle sommes faut-il
rassemblés pour permettre cette
restauration alors au total le budget
nécessaire à ces travaux s'élève à 1,8
million d'euros c'est un montant qui a
été évalué par le château de versailles
et les ingénieurs en charge du projet
les travaux devraient concerner à la
toiture les charpentes les jardins mais
aussi la restauration de la toile le
serment du jeu de paume justement de luc
olivier merson d'après le défunt de
jacques louis david
pour l'heure les députés ne peuvent pas
encore faire de don mardi il s'agissait
seulement d'une présentation du projet
par richard ferrand au bureau de
l'assemblée nationale à l'ensemble des
présidents des groupes politiques
mais le dispositif sera mis en place
prochainement et puis une visite sera
organisée pour leur montrer justement
cette salle du jeu de paume
merci justin brasier pour toutes ces
précisions
[Applaudissements]
l'actualité de la semaine dans les
yvelines c'est mélanie poké qui nous l'a
résumé en 78 secondes là que vit là
aussi impacter la santé au travail des
entreprises yvelinoise ont mis en place
des protocoles pour garantir le
bien-être de leurs salariés
le ministre en charge de cette question
laurent pietra c'est ce qui s'est rendu
sur mes rêves la part variable continue
d'augmenter dans le nombre de
contaminations 40 à 45% des carnets de
france seraient liées aux variants
anglais de lakovic 19
pour brahim bourkia le maître mot est la
solidarité ce restaurateur de
mantes-la-jolie offre depuis plusieurs
semaines des repas gratuits aux
personnes dans le besoin
l aventure de louis burton et de bureau
vallée continue au moins jusqu'en 2026
le récent troisième du vendée globe
change aussi de bateau avec l'achat de
l'occitane en provence voilier de toute
dernière génération
c'était une promesse d' emmanuel macron
les repas un euro au crous pour tous les
étudiants mis en place depuis le mois de
janvier les repas peuvent dorénavant
être pris sur place les élections
régionales et départementales sont
reportés de mars à juin le parlement a
adopté ce report par un vote à main
levée les dates précises ne sont encore
défini le lac rose continue de faire
l'actualité après l' us cussac c'est du
côté de mars que les regards se tournent
le rover persévérance a bien atterri sur
la planète rouge le latmos a développé
une partie de l'électronique qui
commandera super calme un spectromètre
[Musique]
et après cette semaine bien chargée quoi
de mieux que de se détendre le week-end
comme chaque vendredi
s'il y avait 200 go vous propose ses
idées sorties et loisirs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette semaine nous allons parler
alimentation cuisiner avec zéro sucre
c'est possible dérangère philippon a
sorti le 17 février son livre je réussis
ma détox sucre les limites elle est
adepte de recettes à indice glycémique
bas
elle a concocté pour nous des cookies
avec peu de sucre un montage de lucas
houda regarder alors aujourd'hui je ne
ressors de cookies aux noisettes et
pépites de chocolat avec un petit peu de
toi ta tablette pour cela environ 10
ingrédients pour faire à peu près neuf
coups qui on commence par la farine donc
avantage de la farine dans ce monde il
sait qu'il va avoir des glycémies de 30
ans une ferme qui va tenir le bon cap 10
ennemis alors que la farine de blé
blanche en comparaison à un indice
glycémique de 75 ensuite il faut mettre
la poudre d'amandes le son d'avoine qui
apporte beaucoup de fibres et fait
baisser la glycémie et enfin le
bicarbonate
mélangez le tout au nom du dvd au talon
josy du docteur joue mais ça peut être
évidemment nous d'avoine ensuite mettre
le sirop d'agavé qui est un fructose et
remplace le sucre blanc en général dans
une recette classique de cookies où on
peut avoir auprès 100 g de sucre
moi je mets 30 g n'a dû suivre la gav en
temps normal on devrait plutôt mettre 70
g si on voulait avoir une équivalence de
sucre identique
finalement 30 grammes c'est largement
suffisant
troisième étape le gras mettre l'huile
de coco et la purée de cacahuètes la
grèce en indice glycémique 2 0 il faut
tout de même faire attention
dernier ingrédient donc je maigris de
chocolat noir
donc j'ai pris
disco la noire ont trouvé de 60% cacao
également fait un mètre du 70 le
chocolat contient du sucre est notamment
il ne reste plus qu'à former des boucs
d'une épaisseur d'un centimètre et les
mettre au four à 180° pendant 12 minutes
et voilà des cookies avec trois femmes
en sucre kirkouk est classique
c'est encore les vacances scolaires pour
une bonne partie de la semaine
de quoi faire de nombreuses activités
astrid bergère bonsoir sans vous nous
proposez aujourd'hui des idées de
sorties est exactement alors si vous
arrivez à court d'idées pour la deuxième
semaine des vacances
rassurez-vous par chance le temps sera
au beau fixe la semaine prochaine et
permettra les activités en extérieur
alors par exemple à montfort l'amaury il
est possible de participer à un disque
et bien grandeur nature il suffit de se
munir de son téléphone portable de
télécharger l'application kouadio et de
se rendre devant la maison du tourisme
de montfort l'amaury pour connaître les
étapes mais après tout se passe en
autonomie le jeu se fait en autonomie
donc les gamers démarre chez nous et
puis ils peuvent se promener ils ont des
indices sur leur smartphone et ils
peuvent jouer donc dans la ville tout
seul à l'heure qu'il qu'il souhaite et
au moment qu'il souhaite alors la partie
coûte 5 euros il faut être entre deux et
six joueurs dont le but est donc en
partie de découvrir la ville sous un
autre angle
vous me proposez aussi une visite à
maisons laffitte ans et sastre et c'est
ça oui alors dire depuis quelques mois
des portraits en fresque de personnages
historiques ayant lieu en lien avec
maisons laffitte de personnes qui ont
habité ou qui sont passées sont apparus
sur du mobilier de la commune jean
cocteau anne d'autriche ou encore jean
gabin plus de vingt portées sont à
retrouver alors il faut quand même avoir
l'oeil un parce que certains se font
très facilement dans le décor cette
exposition on la doit à christian gay
mis à liason c215 qui est un artiste
urbain assez connu et pour retrouver
plus facilement les oeuvre un plan est
disponible sur le site de l'office du
tourisme de la ville et il y a aussi des
balades en oui c'est ça alors comme je
vous disais il fera normalement beau à
la semaine prochaine on espère
l'occasion
l'occasion de se balader en forêt 1
par exemple dans la forêt de rambouillet
c'est aussi le moment de découvrir des
jolis villages yvelinois com - vide
sûrement siens pour ses lavoirs et ses
moulins ou beau chauve et qui conserve
de très grands vesti de la période
médiévale et pour les enfants et les
familles astrid une application de jeu
de piste en ile-de-france existe oui
alors l'application elle s'appelle
paris-région aventure elle est gratuite
et elle permet de faire des dizaines de
jeux de pistes partout en ile de france
il propose de remonter dans le temps et
de partir sur les traces de louis xiv
marie antoinette ou encore gustave
eiffel et me remercient astrid pour ses
idées sorties cela fait maintenant un an
que la culture est à l'arrêt à cause de
la crise sanitaire à saint quentin en
yvelines les contenus culturels sont
proposés aux quasiment tous en ligne
dorénavant pour en parler nous recevons
aujourd'hui éric allain jeunesse bonjour
bonjour vous êtes vice président de
saint quentin en yvelines en charge de
la culture sur le site internet de saint
quentin en yvelines vous proposer aux
cultures en ligne que contient cette
page d'un culte hors ligne c'est des
contenus pour tous les publics sans
cesse enrichie avec notamment des
contenus multimédias leur appui mais
aussi les différentes activités de nos
et de nos équipements culturels avec
notamment des visites d'ateliers des
jeux des contes de visite virtuelle des
programmes en replay notamment à partir
de prises qui ont été faites soit la
ferme de bel ébat notamment pour
la série des centres de marbella vous
pouvez voir aussi le concert patients
russe qui a été pris dans la prise de
sang a été effectuée au théâtre de 50
tonnes et puis le très nombreux contenus
numériques disponibles proposée par le
musée de la ville la commanderie le
réseau de médiathèques et puis plein de
vidéos plein de belles choses à
découvrir
il y à de nouvelles visites virtuelles
qui ont été mises en ligne récemment
de quoi ça parle alors il ya de virtuel
effectivement qui ont un grand succès
puisque plusieurs centaines de visites
alors il ya une première exposition
peinture donc qui hébergeait la
commanderie donc avec des exposition
collective d'artistes émergents consacré
aux arts numériques les arts plastiques
ne sont sont à l'honneur cette année à
la commanderie et puis il y à aussi donc
l'exposition sous l'égide du musée de la
ville qui s'appelle les a lus et du
design donc comme son nom l'indiqué elle
est consacrée au design on te savoir que
le musée de notre musée à environ 3000
objets de design et de mobilier
concernant les années soixante dix à
donc on vous on a choisit donc de deux
serres de mettre un petit peu rang en
avant le lait l'undr pour cette
exposition qui rencontre un grand grand
succès alors on va parler aussi de la
fête du conte du 27 février au 13 mars
elle va souffler donc ses 20 bougies
exceptionnellement ce sera une
programmation 100% en ligne
qu'est ce que vous avez prévu comme
animation alors donc comme vous le
disiez ça va être cette année sans
course en ligne bien évidemment donc je
rappelle que c'est une astuce est une
action qui est proposée par le réseau
des médiathèques comme vous l'avez dit
donc elle se tiendra du 27 février au 13
mars destinée à tout public
alors il y aura plusieurs événements
avec dans un premier temps un appel à
l'écriture qui a été organisée par là
pour recueillir des comptes écrit par
les saint quentinois
et puis
ton du 8 mars au 8 avril le conteur
stéphane des feux qui est un conteur
professionnel racontera les comptes qui
l'ignorent non plus le plus
et voilà parmi tous ceux qu'il aura
reçues sont donc tout ça bien sûr
disponible en ligne sur le portail
culture en ligne de du portail de saint
quentin en yvelines et à partir du 27
février
il y aura deux veillées de contes pour
frissonner de plaisir à l'occasion donc
des soirées des fameuses soirées chair
de poule
que les habitués connaissent bien ou
encore la saga serpent rêve qui propose
trois épisodes pour savoir tout sur
l'origine des rêves voilà un petit peu
le programme de cette fête du conte etc
à destination et des adultes et des
enfants comme ça ils mentent ou publics
communiquent menace alors ouais c'est un
bon moment d'habitude et c'est un moment
merveilleux où on voit les enfants qui
rient missouri qui trépignent voilà
forcément ce sera derrière des écrans
mais on a tous appris à s'adapter puis
on est sûr que ça va pas durer très
longtemps
on croise les doigts pour que l'année
prochaine on puisse tous se retrouver et
que toute cette période un peu noir soit
loin derrière nous c'est tout ce qu'on
souhaite en tout cas
aimer dernière question est ce qu'il y à
d'autres événements culturels en ligne
après voir peut-être alors dans
l'immédiat ce qui va surtout occupé le
printemps c'est les événements dont je
vous ai parlé bien sûr ou mets en taule
tous les équipements culturels
continuent à travailler continuer à
produire donc sont ces contenus sont
régulièrement alimenté sur le portail de
l'agglomération de sky donc au fur et à
mesure bien sûr les personnes qui
consultent régulièrement le sic sont
informés de tous les événements
culturels qui s'y produiront bien
évidemment on est toujours dans
l'espérance d'une sortie de crise alors
bon on se dit que avec un peu de chance
peut-être qu'on pourra retrouver le
chemin des salles de spectacle le chemin
de la commanderie mai
tous les équipements culturels n'ont
qu'une hâte c'est d'ouvrir mais on
s'adaptera et on produira en fonction de
la situation sanitaire des contenus
toujours renouvelée et toujours à
destination de tous les publics
merci beaucoup eric allain jeunesse
d'avoir été notre invité est le site it
we can de se poursuit avec eléonore pour
parler de l'actualité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à la une la semaine prochaine nous
reviendrons sur la visite du ministre
délégué en charge des transports jean
baptiste djebbari à versailles il a
visité le mobile à bout sont notamment
implantés l'équipe systèmes de transport
autonome du groupe transdev et
l'institut pour la transition
énergétique vd comme la visite s'est
notamment concentré sur la mobilité
routière automatisée avec la découverte
d'une navette autonome électriques ou
encore d'un simulateur de conduite
les détails de cette visite à retrouver
la semaine prochaine sur tb les 78 et
pour refermer ce 7,8 week-end votre
rendez-vous en partenariat avec les
surligneurs ce collectif qui décrypte
les déclarations des personnalités
publiques et politiques
aujourd'hui retour sur la procédure
engagée par le ministère de l'intérieur
pour dissoudre le groupe d'extrême
droite génération identitaire on écoute
vincent couronne docteur en droit à
l'université versailles saint quentin et
fondateur des surligneurs
est ce bien raisonnable de vouloir
dissoudre génération identitaire
l'association d'extrême droite qui
prétend défendre l'europe avec des
campagnes de communication frontière où
ils sont censés empêcher les migrants de
passer cette association est sous le
coup d'une menace du ministre de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin qui veulent
et dissoudre pour nicolas bay député
européen et membre du rassemblement
national
on ne peut pas comme ça à dissoudre une
association seulement parce qu'elle
déplorait le gouvernement mais il faut
dire qu'il a raison on ne peut pas
dissoudre une association comme motifs
personnels ou politiques cela nous
renverrait à cette époque post mai 68 où
le pouvoir qu'ont pido liens avaient
tenté d'instaurer un contrôle politique
sur la création des associations
tentatives
fort heureusement avortée mais nicolas
bay oublient une chose notre droit
permet de dissoudre toute association
incitant à la discrimination à la haine
ou à la violence
on se souvient de la dissolution
d'associations de supporteurs du psg et
cela n'avait posé aucun problème même
chose lorsqu en 2020 emmanuel macron à
10 ou plusieurs associations prônant un
islam radical
mais ces règles vous me direz peuvent
être foulés aux pieds par l'opportunisme
politique d'un ministre l'intérieur
occupé à faire de la com oui mais dans
ce cas il reste un recours à génération
identitaire c'est le conseil d'état et
il n'hésitera pas à annuler la
dissolution si jamais elle est est
illégale mais quand on regarde les faits
de cette association on a du mal à voir
en quoi elle n'incite pas à la haine est
donc en quoi on ne pourrait pas la
dissoudre
c'est la fin de votre 7,8 week-end merci
de l'avoir suivi l'information revient
lundi à 18h en direct dans le 7-8
journal présenté par grégory canale et
d'ici là je souhaite une très belle
soirée et un très bon week end
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ans
[Musique]